will he be the nominee I think he will
be the nominee this is uh house leader
Kevin McCarthy uh talking to Maria
Bartiromo on Fox Business uh about Trump
and DeSantis try to make some sense out
of what he's saying here all of that the
policies that you mentioned of the body
Administration is one reason that Donald
Trump is leading in the polls right now
what's your take on this that as we see
more indictments of Donald Trump he
seems to be gaining in terms of
popularity with the public will he be
the nominee I think he will be the
nominee and the thing is
president Trump is stronger today than
he was in 2016 or 2020. and there's a
reason why they saw the policies of what
he was able to do with America putting
America First making our economy
stronger we didn't have inflation we we
didn't have these battles around the
world we didn't look weak around the
world well it looks like Ron DeSantis is
now trying to work with New York
colleague College who are pushed or
pushing for a shutdown yeah but I don't
think that would work anywhere a
shutdown would only give strength to the
Democrats it would give the power to
Biden it wouldn't pay our troops it
wouldn't pay our border agents more
people would be coming across I actually
want to achieve something and this is
where president Trump is so smart that
he was successful in this you know
president Trump is beating Biden right
now in the polls yeah we have the poll
let's show it he's stronger than he has
ever been in this process and look I I
served with Ron DeSantis he's not at the
same level as president Trump by any
shape or form he would not have gotten
elected without president Trump's
endorsement and so I believe our best
step forward pass our appropriation
bills so we're stronger take the wokism
out secure our border to make America
strong oh there's there's a lot there
okay so first off I agree with the good
stuff that McCarthy said about the Trump
presidency which is why I voted for
Trump the second time around right and I
was very vocal in my support about Trump
what's odd there's a couple odd things
first off Donald Trump is still again
whether you're magabase whether you
voted for Trump like Trump you like to
say this doesn't matter Donald Trump is
still saying the election was stolen
from him right it seems to me that it
would be a problem in a functioning
Society if the leader of the house was
openly backing a guy who says that the
last election was stolen like he's
basically saying oh the whole thing's a
sham and this guy's going yeah the whole
thing's a jam I'm gonna back him
um it's a little bit odd there and
that's not to take away again from the
good things that Trump has done uh but
here's this at this responding to well
really he's responding to McCarthy but
going after Trump on this as well
what is your take on the fact that
speaking speaking McCarthy not who was
leadership back then doesn't think that
you're a fifth belief
well look I would say I mean I think
that if you look at what's happened with
DC Republicans uh they worked uh very
closely you know look Donald Trump he
supported Kevin McCarthy very strongly
for speaker I don't think he would have
won the speaker vote Donald Trump was
instrumental in him earning that
speakers gavel and they worked hand in
glove really throughout his whole
presidency they were on the same team on
every major spending bill that came down
the the Pike and they ended up together
adding 7.8 trillion dollars to our
national debt never in a four-year
period has that much been added than
what they did together and so he said
that we're different we are different
because in Florida we run budget
surpluses we've paid down almost 25
percent of our state's debt just since
I've been Governor all the debt all the
way up for all of Florida's history
we've knocked off almost 25 percent of
it so it's a much different approach uh
to where we're doing it right we have
the number one rated economy in the
country we've cut taxes we've expanded
school choice and we've delivered on in
a way that has made the state
sustainable uh I am not somebody uh who
the DC establishment wants to see up
there there's no question
I think that last line is the key part
it's like McCarthy in a way doesn't want
a guy like Ron DeSantis who's actually
going to drain the swamp and change
things now I I happen to like Kevin
McCarthy you know I've interviewed him
many times including uh in that very
room that he was just sitting in uh with
Maria Bartiromo so it's not a shot at
him personally but there's also a weird
dynamic here because Trump backed
McCarthy for the speakership as DeSantis
referenced the base hates McCarthy they
think he's like McConnell and everything
else and and Lindsey Graham like they
think he's sort of the ultimate swamp
creature so you've got Trump backing the
ultimate swamp creature while the base
hates the swamp like there's just all
these strange Dynamics